so salesforce com what what we'll what
we'll do is we'll show you the roadmap
to success here so this is what
Salesforce puts out as kind of their
road map to victory as far as setting up
and administering and developing
Salesforce platforms this could be for a
company that's already existing and
going in and making some changes to an
already existing instance or it could be
someone that just purchased a brand new
sales force in Sisson and needs a
full-scale implementation can you start
so the first thing that we'll talk about
is I justifying key contact excuse me
and Salesforce has several folks that
they they kind of want to highlight and
they actually give names to these are
what we call key contacts so they call
the executive sponsor that's usually a
CEO or vp of sales or someone that's an
executive level in the food chain and
that person becomes kind of the champion
and they're going to set the vision
he'll add value he'll help with adoption
and he'll communicate strategy through
aligning a goal I can't stress how
important this person is they really
need to be someone that is interested in
making sales force a part of the culture
if this is if the executive sponsor
isn't on board if you're going to have
all kinds of trouble so you need to make
sure that this person is ready and
willing to do what needs to be done in
order to implement Salesforce next we
have what we call the project owner and
a lot of times from my perspective the
project owner is usually the system
administrator because in since I tend to
work with small to mid-sized firms
sometimes the project owner the system
admin the power user are all the same
person so but the project owner there
they're kind of under the executive
sponsor and they guide the project to
completion they should be a process
expert and they should be able to map
them into Salesforce you can configure
he understands his company and he's
willing to provide training and support
to to the folks of end users in in the
firm next we have the system
administrator in this person from what I
find a lot of
is kind of an inside sales person that
it is landed on their desk sometimes
they have actual certified admins in
place sometimes they do not this admin
person I need to get them up to speed
and I need to help them understand the
day-to-day application how to manage it
how to configure it it also helps a
thorough process expert and they also
provide continuing training and support
they're almost there kind of a liaison
for the project owner your system admins
usually tend to be less user facing as
say a project owner of power user but if
they're all the same person then so be
it then we have the power user and the
power user serves as a direct liaison to
users say sales and they're going to
ensure that the application meets the
data game needs for losers so you've got
your executive sponsor your project
owner your systems administrator your
powers so the next thing we're going to
do is we're going to define a vision and
what do I mean by that well we're going
to create a kind of mission statement
for the salesforce.com implementation
for the firm here I have a one that I
would that I just kind of came up with
but this would be determined mainly by
the executive sponsor in this fourth
book to new your admin your power user
your executive sponsor and the it and
your power users should all have a say
and sometimes even the end users the
sales teams or whoever the user is would
have a safe with the vision might be
more you can get people all together and
a part of the process as far as design
and business requirements gathering you
can end up with kind of a wee culture
and a wee attitude we came up with this
together and we all signed off on it
together and that way you better user
duck because the whole name of the game
with this is user da few people don't
use it you may as well throw it in the
trash it needs to have users that are
entering information updating statuses
getting tasks completing those tasks and
running through and doing their due
diligence as as users so our vision for
this one is to build and maintain
efficient business processes user
adoption and our
I using the salesforce.com CRM platform
so after we define our vision we need to
map our business objectives and this is
a very simple flow chart here of what a
business objective map might look like
so here in this situation we have
corporate needs self generated leads and
those all become kind of a total lead in
a bucket and then they're moving into
some sort of qualification process and
then the ones that don't qualify are
going to be closed in a closed lead and
the others are going to get proposals
and then have sales activity and they're
going to move on down the line and then
in the end we would have some sort of
sale and our output here of new
customers so this would be kind of this
is what we this is what our business
objectives map should look like so after
we have our business objectives in place
we're then going to create a rollout
plan and this is our plan for success by
definition it's a multi-faceted approach
to salesforce.com problems and issues in
the process so the first thing I do is I
go in and I do a discovery interview
with all of my my key contacts as well
as as many users as I possibly can and
all I'm doing is finding out where the
problems are um so we you know we're
looking for things that Salesforce can
solve or making it to where users want
to use the platform so just a few of
these from some interviews I've had in
the past people say things like you know
a snapshot of needs and what status is
there with key metrics can be created is
it different it is difficult to do data
entry wanted by management when the
field sales force is an intuitive it
doesn't mess with my calendar commercial
sales managers were interested in using
it for product management we need to
create a system of tasks and reminders
lead status reports all this stuff is um
sorry all this stuff is in these
discovery interviews
let's see yeah so after we do our
discovery and I've done my business
requirements gathering in my discovery
interviews and I have my map my process
that I want it to look like now I'm
going to look at current process issues
and I like to give this example because
i had an automation background I come
from industrial automation and pneumatic
valve sales my previous life so in this
situation we're looking at a bottling
application and the in this process here
we have a hundred bottles coming into
the process at 100 units per hour first
process is a hundred units the capacity
is under units and they just fly right
through there's no lag at all the second
process there's only 75 units capacity
so now we have 25 sitting in front of
process to process three only has 50 so
now we have 50 sitting in front of
process three and then process or they
sling right on by and hundreds of feet
of per hour the interesting thing to
notice is the lowest capacity process is
always going to be the output and you
know understand and I'm not saying that
a sales funnel looks just like a
automation process but the same way the
capacity can constrain the output with
your you know your input of bottles in
your output of bottles the lowest in the
process will be the the tightest
constrained and I think that it does
make sense so I said notice that in this
manufacturing process the output is
always equal to the lowest capacity
process no matter the output of the
other processes so I'd like to call this
manufacturing customers so here we have
a situation where I've got different
types of leads coming in we have earned
media we have trade shows and we have
key marketing initiatives and those all
come together and let's just pretend
that says 200 needs instead of two and a
quarter I didn't get my throne so our
qualification step here or process one
has two hundred leads per month and
let's say that our yield is fifty
percent of those leads will actually
make it to the intermediate sales step
would be some sort of sales activity
from our outside sales team so here we
have two hundred leads a month with a
yield of fifty percent that gives us 100
leads a month that are actually getting
to that intermediate sales step and
let's say the capacity is 100 leads a
month here with a yield of ten percent
so now we're getting ten leads per month
and down here at our clothes if we have
ten lengths per month field sixty
percent of those that means we're going
to get six new customers and you'll
notice that the new customers is equal
to lowest capacity process just like in
our bottling application so now we need
to talk about balancing the process so
if i take this seem set up here and I
just tweaked a couple of things so here
I've got the exact same situation but
instead of ten percent yield I can
somehow through some activity raise that
capacity to twenty percent it gives me
20 more leads a month so by the end of
the month if I'm still only yielding
sixty percent that's 12 leads a month
which is 12 new customers by just
changing the yield on this one process
we were able to double a number of new
customers so here's another example so
here I've got a situation where there's
the original one again and here I've got
up this 50 60 and we raised our capacity
to 125 so that leads to 12.5 leads a
month which gives us seven and a half
new customers so we can also tweak
capacity in multiple processes to try
and maximize the number of new customers
that we can get out the back in the
process and this is what really what I
think's a little source is it's a way to
take a raw material leads and turn them
in to new customers and you do that
through a custom automation email
templates making sure that salespeople
are well trained and using the system in
a way that is the most efficient good
developing good developer work on the
front end so the back end is seamless
and people don't really see an issue
working with it salesforce1 mobile is a
great way to interact
with Salesforce for someone that doesn't
necessarily have any background in it
the Salesforce platform tends to be a
little obtuse to new users but if you
use salesforce1 which I'll do a demo for
you shortly view salesforce1 it's almost
like a facebook functionality it's very
intuitive and it's very easy to use so
here we have we're going to influence
our quality through lead qualification
so here's a situation where market
support is to qualify leads in
Salesforce before they get to outside
sales teams and this will increase
capacity increase yield and allow for
the maximization of your customers so
here we have 225 weeds from the same 225
leaves moving working with and we come
in here with our capacity of 225 our
yield a sixty percent and that gives us
135 leads a month as a 225 that are
actually going to make it into the sales
process to our outside team this is
important because a lot of times what
I'll see in the field is companies will
just take 250 needs and dump them into a
Salesman will have every month and this
causes some pretty major issues that we
get to do a little further along the
presentation but I call cherry-picking
so what'll happen is you give the
salesman 250 needs which he could never
in a million years be able to handle all
this out and he cherry-picks the ones
that he knows he can sell and he's going
to choose the ones that he's the kind of
industry that he sold to before and he
thinks he's going to be successful
because he knows he's a good salesman he
knows who to contact so what happens is
he's chasing his tail and you know if
you have someone in front of the process
gleaning those 200 t5 leads from our
sales guy and turning them into 135 and
in a perfect situation scheduling those
needs for the outside sales team you
know now we can up our yield we can
upper yield you get up our capacities
but in this particular process here our
qualification step is yielded sixty
percent instead of 50 and then are
easier intermediate sales too because
we're getting better qualified leads and
to our sales team more
and we're going to be able to yield
fifteen percent to the 10 and then our
capacity on the end is 20.25 beats a
month that's 12.15 new owner or new
customers so basically what Salesforce
does for marketing and sales and IT not
only did collect contact information and
allow us to do some great reporting in
marketing kind of work it allows us to
track campaign we can cases in solutions
but really from a holistic point of view
all you're doing is turning leads and
your customers and then there's the
backhand side they call the service
cloud which is kind of supporting those
new customers down the road to make sure
if they have issues they're taken care
of you want to make sure that things you
properly assign an escalated but this is
the basic functionality of the
Salesforce platform in a nutshell so
here we have an actual situation that I
walked into and in this situation I have
and this was an existing sales force
word they were using leads as accounts
that accounts as opportunities so that
was mass duplication there was a major
data corruption no one trusted the
system everybody pretty much hated it it
was a formality that the sales guys had
to go through an or himself but no one
was really using it in the way at the
Met views um so we have over here we
have corporate leads meaning and this is
kind of interesting the corporate leads
were are our executive sponsor and the
organization you know through our media
trade show Weeds you know email a
contact website you know all the kinds
of marketing stuff that a corporation
does the salespeople for these leads
would get a 1 Commission and then if the
salesperson generated their own leads
they would get a higher commission so we
have 840 leads per year were
self-generated 865 or corporate leads so
that gave us 1705 leads for the year so
and when I kind of moved down the line
here 54.2 percent of them 925 leads were
just sitting in open status just
completely open no one had ever
contacted them and you know they're just
kind of sitting there and open there was
forty-six percent of them got to a
qualification of what they called lead
info shared and what that meant is that
the the salesperson had claimed that
lead as as their own so as you can
possibly expect what was going on is
everybody was just entering everything
they could and putting it into this lead
info shared for their own self-generated
least because they got more Commission
in our close the leads category only to
only 40 leads of 1700 were closed and
when I say a closed lead especially in
sales for swinging by clothes lead isn't
necessarily that the lead is dead never
to be seen again we're actually going to
hit those needs with low cost high
return on investment marketing because
just because they're not qualified now
doesn't mean they will be a year from
now two years now and we can schedule
automated the newsletter blast email
merge blasts we can do email with
letterhead we can do what's called an
email template and it'll look like a
personalized email if you beat I'm
trigger would go off at certain times 30
days 60 days 90 days anything you want
on those and eventually you might
squeeze a few more a few more new
customers out of that pool so proposals
if you look it was at 4.05 percent
that's 30 leads per year and then
magically 27 systems were sold so this
is the kind of thing you'll find with a
Salesforce platform it's in use and what
you can do is you can actually look at
this flow and see what's happening they
aren't opening the leads their
cherry-picking leads they aren't getting
qualified properly and the only ones
that are actually in the system here
were the ones that were sold
so that that would be our current
process issues so once we figure these
out and we have our discovery
information and our business requirement
information we can then propose a lead
qualification process so basically what
we can do is we can take a key
performance indicators and they're
attracting Salesforce in real time and
we can use something called a data
validation rule to ensure that all key
performance indicators are required
before the lead can be saved so and at
this point I like to kind of bring up a
analogy of a large next small net so
when we do lead qualification I always
recommend that my clients have someone
that in sales that their whole job is to
qualify leads and that person will then
use our key performance indicators and
reporting capabilities to ensure that
the leads that qualify and get to the
proper outside salesperson and that the
the clothes leads end up in the right
place so that that's what it's doing is
raising our quality and it's raising our
capacity so when we you know I don't
like to just say okay this keeper of
this grouping of key performance
indicators is a hot eight this is a cold
lead and just leave it stagnant forever
I believe in the large net small net
philosophy meaning it if times are tough
and there's not a whole lot of fish in
the water a fisherman will cast a larger
net so we want to be constantly tweaking
these key performance indicators to
widen the net or make the next smaller
based on the number of potential clients
because the goal here is to keep the
outside sales team busy oh there's so
much waste that goes on in the business
world with with sales teams that aren't
busy and if you can keep them busy
you're raising capacity and our league
qualification filter is going to be
filtering leads and making sure the
quality of capacity visible leads that
actually get to our sales team so what
we'll do is we'll actually raise the
amount of you
summers out the back end here's an
example of key performance indicators so
this is let's pretend that we're talking
about heating ventilation and air
conditioning firm and we're looking at
things like number of trucks number of
employees industry type provided
services trade organization memberships
top-line revenue percentage of
residential commercial business and we
can use these key performance indicators
to adjust the size of our net so here's
one that we would call say a warmly
designation and everyone would kind of
talk about what they think of one need
is and then we would come up with key
metrics that would designate them as one
so if they had five trucks they have 15
employees their residential like
commercial and they provide residential
commercial HVAC they've got trade
organizations there in his akka and
total top line revenue is one and a half
million so that we would say for this
month would be our warm lean designation
and depending on the number of leads
that come in every month we can alter
what a warm week designation might be
and that kind of adjust our net to
smaller and larger dependent on how busy
our sales guys are if there are cold and
dead leads if our key metrics are lower
than our quality standards for any given
period these things can be categorized
as cold and they get sent to outside
sales teams as such and you know this
would be set up to barely be you know
low priority but we can also let our
sales teams do the high return on
investment low-cost marketing or you can
have your lead qualification person do
that kind of depends on the business if
the lead is found to be dead closed and
it can be listed as such and remove from
reports of dashboards but you keep it
for future reference as we discussed
earlier okay so we have a
we dinner discover interviews we looked
at our process issues when we developed
a lead qualification process so another
thing that salesforce.com offers is a
security and access
ok
more were you looking to see
ok second glass the skirt